bill birds calling Wyatt oh my god now
this is a miracle I mean what the [ __ ]
bill yes are you bill I mean let me ask
you something bill I mean you never
called me Billy Wow bill this is you
know what because I've been getting a
lot of calls and no offense to anybody
that else is called but this is probably
this is the this is the probably the
most shocking one thank you Bill and you
know I'm you calling it is like it's
kind of like a Sinatra moment to me you
know in comedy Ron Howard but uh but hey
Bill also um thank you for calling and
also I want to ask you if one day you
would do our podcast I'd be great all
right thank you we record at my house I
live in Hollywood it's easy what do you
you look at the silver like where do you
live it's a big place bill
well um thank you so much for calling
him bill I love you and I'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you in town now are you on the road
I love you bill thank you for coffee
[Laughter]
I couldn't do it anymore
doing anymore Bobby just hung up on Bill
burr I think I just said goodbye
[Music]